this guy is controlling his friend like
a video game character this thing is so
cool and I so want to try it I would put
it on all my children and see if I could
get them to do chores Hey
it's bedtime oh we went to meet Alan to
find out how we made a sci-fi superpower
into an awesome reality I made it out of
a remote-control toy car basically and
now I can remotely control people who
agree to wear this thing the reactions
were actually very fearful people didn't
like the idea of messing with someone's
brain so a lot of people were sort of
like kicked out by the whole thing they
thought it was kind of scary which i
think is really funny it's controlling
it so how can you take over someone
else's mind
Alan is controlling his friends using
their vestibular system that's
responsible for balance small canals in
your inner ear move fluid around and as
that fluid sloshes back and forth it
excites hairs which send electrical
signals into the brain Alan's helmet is
able to override those signals okay oh
okay
do copper-plated electrodes are fitted
to the side of the helmet ready to shock
the wearer by hitting the left button on
the remote control the electrical
current is sent to the right side of the
helmet when this happens the brain tries
to compensate by leaning the body in the
opposite direction
Alan's helmet is able to trick the wear
into believing that ground is in a
different direction oh oh my god oh god
if all of a sudden the ground shifts
beneath you you walk in the direction to
try and stabilize I'm being pooled I'm
being pulled over in that direction
being able to push left on a joystick on
a controller and then seeing the person
in front of you immediately start
turning to the left it's it's kind of a
power trip
thanks Alan we'll let you get back to
abusing your power over your friends
you